so i'm now going to go live on instagram
you guys want to bet they're going to go
where's your mask they're going to tap
their finger not wearing masks
and forcing their way into stores
you're mistaken sir even hospitals but
you're making me wear a mask
otherwise you're not you're going to
deny me service fake news this is the
world's biggest fraud
canadian covid deniers and those opposed
to public health measures
who rail against the science and health
warnings
are seen as a fringe movement
a loud minority but health workers warn
their growing tentacles
are now reaching into the homes of
ordinary canadians
and threatening to undermine our
pandemic response
it's frightening it's absolutely
frightening
dr joy hatley is a family physician in
kingston ontario
over three decades working in the
operating and emergency rooms
she's developed a steady hand and is no
stranger to confronting
medical misinformation but in all her
years
she's never faced anything like this
a parallel pandemic of disinformation
covet 19 conspiracies hatley and her
colleagues now regularly see patients
who believe the virus is a hoax
it's now affecting my ability to care
for my patients because
there's a trust factor and there's an
uncertainty on their part
and they're not sure whether or not they
actually should be complying with public
health measures
it's a topic of conversation at most
dinner tables
including her own
hatley started hearing these pandemic
conspiracy theories
from members of her own family they are
all very intelligent people
they are all very learned people they
have many university degrees
and yet my family members in the early
days of the pandemic
were sending me things that were 100
percent conspiracy theory
including her father sharing videos like
this one
it's about creating fear so that people
will not ask any questions
containing widely debunked claims that
the covet 19 test
is fake and that bill gates is secretly
inserting
trackable microchips into the vaccines
so i went back to my dad and i said dad
i'm sorry i worry about you
like that's just nuts and he goes well
you never know
like a lot of things have happened in my
lifespan i could never have imagined
when i was a child
so i said to dad the first thing you
need to do dad when one of your friends
sends you one of these things is look at
where it's from
but when hatley searched for the video's
source she was overwhelmed
by the sheer number of sites and social
media accounts
spreading the claims yeah i everyone's
confused this is huge
you know and if they hear a strong voice
they tend to latch onto it and then
follow it right down a rabbit hole
hatley is also the district chair of the
ontario medical association
the oma just commissioned a study to see
how widespread these conspiracies have
become
they found 105 000 ontarians discussing
the pandemic as a hoax
with about three quarters spreading
misinformation
and that's confusing for the population
and then you add to that
the fact that we really haven't had a
strong
individual in canada to provide
information to canadian citizens with a
single voice
they've been hearing from voices all
over the place
[Music]
people are afraid and there's a
continuous sense of disaster
university of waterloo professor carmen
celastini is an expert in conspiracies
and says the pandemic has produced a
plethora of different theories
which tend to follow a similar theme
they believe
that using the laws around covid and
isolation and keeping us home
is the catalyst to a cabal starting a
new world order
while the stories might sound silly
celestini says their membership is
growing
exponentially the pandemic has produced
a perfect storm
of fear frustration and isolation
with more time spent online it's not
people who are uneducated or people who
are you know on the lowest end of the
social economic
tiers it's people everywhere that are
being
brought into this and they're afraid
they're you know they don't have jobs
they're alone
so they're turning to communities on the
internet
[Music]
susan says she's witnessed that
transformation
up close she asked us not to reveal her
identity because she lives at home with
her mother
afraid she could be kicked out for
speaking up
to learn that my mom was like that it
was a shock
growing up she says her mother was her
hero a successful
award-winning businesswoman with no
history of conspiracy beliefs
before the pandemic she was very mad
she's someone who was really social so
the idea of social distancing and not
seeing people
it was making her suffer susan says her
mother who never used computers before
the pandemic
started spending a lot of time online
and came across an open letter written
by a controversial catholic archbishop
claiming covet 19 was a global
conspiracy
against god and humanity she told me
we're in world war iii people are
suffering for nothing
that's when really things started to get
really really crazy
she says her mother started attending
protests claiming the pandemic was a
hoax
and refusing to stay home or wear a mask
when susan tried challenging those
beliefs she says her mother
threatened to kick her out of the house
there was no more relationship at that
point
at the end of the conversation i told
her that i missed her
what do you mean by that that she she
isn't the same person
it's like someone else was in the house
who looked like my mom and sounded like
her
but it's not the person i remember do
you feel like you've lost some piece of
her
yeah she's gone
there are many canadians who have family
members
um who are falling for for
stories or theories that just seem so
far-fetched and kyle matthews warns the
consequences
reach far beyond family feuds the expert
in online extremism at concordia
university
is now part of a team investigating how
covet conspiracies
are spreading he says the disinformation
super spreaders
include an eclectic mix of anti-vaxxer
anti-immigrant and far-right hate groups
and much of their disinformation is now
focused
on vaccines we are seeing you know a lot
of chatter online
basically suggesting that the vaccine is
some global conspiracy by bill gates to
track people
we've picked up the chinese basically
spreading
falsehoods about western vaccines that
they can't be trusted
chinese state media is blaming the u.s
pfizer vaccine for the deaths of around
two dozen people in norway
norwegian health authorities said the
elderly patients were frail and very
sick
and they found no direct link to the
injections but those chinese claims
are now being heavily promoted by
anti-vaccine groups
i think the wider concern is that if
these groups continue
what impact will that have on canadians
wanting to get vaccinated
will it set back our recovery
will impact our public health
[Music]
back in kingston dr hatley says that's
what worries her
the most we have a problem if we're
relying on the vaccine
to be the answer to uh to the end of the
pandemic or as close as we can get
to the end of the pandemic you know the
anti-vaxxers were
already very well organized before covet
hit
and so they're rolling out i mean they
have buses that drive down the street
and encourage people not to get their
vaccine
and and they play on fear these people
who
tout conspiracy theory they actually
take advantage of people's fears hatley
was able to reconcile with her father
she says he backed away from the
conspiracies after one of his friends
a 40 year old died from covid19
hatley and the ontario medical
association are also pushing back
publishing this article fact-checking
some of the most common
conspiracy claims and that's what i
would advise every canadian citizen to
do
look at the source of the information
that you are reading
is it come from a credible source does
it come from a scientist
does it come from a physician does it
come from a physician
who specifically is an epidemiologist
if it does open it up read it consume it
if it's not from one of those credible
sources
please do yourself a favor push it aside
and
find credible information